covern Lichtenhagen meine erste Frage
ist
ist dein Lied sie wirklich dein Freund
ich habe mein PC ist mein Freund ich
Prozent arbeiten vieler Mezzo und
könnte gar nicht ohne PC Leben
rechtfertigen und könnt mich um 14
Leben und wer also echte ich hab mein PC
lieb auch wenn er manchmal ein paar
Macken hat aber das kann ja echte
Menschen auf
einen Zeitrahmen ist auf dem Handel
auch hier lassen sich dadurch nicht
leichter machen das jetzt mal
es ist meine Freiheit kommt
um mehr habe ich jetzt einen leider
nicht also ich bin aber ich bin glaube
ich auch zur Argument was zu leisten und
wird das wahrscheinlich habe ich hatten
Super Altenfurt ihnen mp3-player von
kriegsdrohung» der damals 30 Uhr Ehrung
gekostet hat
und ich haben tolles Schrott Handy ihres
Prozent da mal so SMS verschicken kann
aber auch aber ich nicht mal die
50-prozentige drei Funktion hat oder mit
den nicht Fotos schießen kann kann an
Autos auf sowas eigentlich auch nicht
obwohl es eigentlich geht von einer
Sekunde was zu haben aber nicht absagen
ich auch nicht oft wird nicht aber ich
werde mir ein dass ich das nicht brauche
wo man sozusagen die Lebensversicherung
wo ist bei jedem Kauf
das ist hier die Frage ob ich auch Obst
bei Apple Kaufering nicht hoffen gerne
äpfel aber jetzt nicht am Ring bei
Apple